[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن نتعامل مع موسم المربعانيه كبعث ثقافي
وبعد مناخي فهي من الموروث واهالينا
يتعاملون مع موسم المربعانيه كبعت اقتصادي
وبعد حياتي فمع دخولي موسم المربعانيه
يبدون يصدرون التمور المخزنه ومع دخولها
يبدون قصون اوراق وغصون الاشجار
للاستخدامات المتنوعه في البناء والاواني
المنزليه والعصي فقبل المربعانيه يكون
الماء موجود في غصون الاشجار وبعد
المربعانيه تغرق الاشجار وتكون خير صالحه
للقصر فقط الاشجار بعد ذبولها ويخضروا ساق
النبتي وهو هشيم اذا ما اراد الله اتمام
حاجته اتتك على وشك وانت
مقيمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فمع دخول مربعانيه الشتاء يتوقف الماء عن
الجريان في غصون الاشجار وقصها خلال هذه
الفتره يمنع التسوس ومع دخول المربعانيه
القيظ يكثر جريان الماء في غصون الاشجار
فتبدا تفرز ماده يميل لونها الى الاحمر او
الاصفر تستخدم للتطبب تسمى بالصمغ اشهرها
صمغ الطلح وخلال هذه الايام صياد العصي
يترقبون غصون الاشجار استعدادا لقصها
حملته العصا للضعفه اوجب حملها علي ولا
اني تحنيت من الكبر ولكنني الزمت نفسي
حملها ليعلمها ان المقيمه
على سفر
[موسيقى]